Okay, we're starting course two on congestion control and
streaming. And we'll first talk about congestion control. In
particular, what is congestion control and why do we
need it? Simply put, the goal of congestion control
is to fill the Internet's pipes without overflowing them.
So to think about this in terms of an
analogy, suppose you have a sink. And you're filling
that sink with water. Well, how should you control
the faucet? Too fast and the sink overflows.
Too slow and you are not efficiently filling up
your sink. So what you would like to do is to fill the bucket as quickly as
possible without overflowing. The solution here is to
watch the sink. And as the sink begins to
overflow, we want to slow down how fast
we're filling it. That's effectively how congest control works.